parmi toutes les personnes que tu as
cassé dans les médias est-ce qu'il y en
a plus aujourd'hui à qui tu as envie de
demander pardon et laquelle je casse pas
pour le plaisir de casser je dis ce que
je pense et des fois ce que je pense
c'est cassant mais c'est pas pour faire
de la peine je dis ce que je pense des
gens donc voilà et dans un métier où ça
se fait pas vraiment ça peut surprendre
mais pourquoi tu as côté un peu fouillis
mais franchement entre nous c'est pas
fou il maire de o sens presse à scandale
vraiment c'est que ce qui m'intéresse
c'est la nature humaine et les
faiblesses des gens connus c'est une
façon finalement de démystifier
peut-être un peu les gens connus parce
que les gens connus c'est avant tout on
est connu c'est des gens ça passe par
ces questions là ce que tu veux
démontrer bah ça passe par des questions
intimes parce qu'effectivement c'est
dans l'intimité que tout le monde et le
plus semblable
tu dis souvent faim tu me dis souvent
qu'il faut pas trop déconner avec la
religion parce que toi qui rit tapper de
brouille en enfer franchement thierry tu
serais pas un peu con c'est vrai que
c'est un peu con de dire il ya deux
choses que je respecte c'est le roi et
le pas bon ça semble un peu bizarre on
dit ça pour donner un genre c'est du
marketing
en fait je crois pas vraiment je crois
que moi j'aimerais mieux qu'ils aient un
roi en france c'est vrai c'est sincère
là aussi ça ne fait pas que des amis ce
truc là parce que pour les français
après 200 ans de propagande républicaine
ils confondent un peu louis saez adolf
hitler quand même quelque part donc ça
ne fait pas que du bien ce truc là le
pape c'est pareil pour moi la personne
que je préfère au monde c'est le pape
surtout celui là alors j'aime pas qu'on
rigole avec la religion d'abord parce
qu'on tire pas sur les ambulances je
trouve que c'est un peu facile de faire
l'anticléricalisme il ya 90 ans qu'on en
fait je suis sans doute un peu con oui
de croire que que si je suis pas gentil
sur la terre que si je fais du mal je
vais en enfer brûlés dans des flammes ça
c'est un peu con mais on peut appeler ça
le karma j'ai pas envie d'avoir un
mauvais karma
c'est déjà un peu moins con le dire
comme ça non si ton père débarqué là sur
le plateau comme dans ses treize soirées
où la conscience d'arthur tout à l'heure
tu dirais quoi je dirais que c'est un
peu grâce à lui que je suis là parce que
je crois qu'il voulait être journaliste
et puis là pas pu et que en tous les cas
il m'a toujours donné le goût de la
presse de l'info de la vérité je crois
que toutes les vérités sont bonnes à
dire c'est quelque chose qui lui qui
comprend et je crois que je dirais ben
voila tu vois simple c'est pas seulement
parce que tu es mon père que je suis là
c'est aussi parce qu'en 54 tu m'as fait
goûter europe 1 matin alors je lui dirai
merci mais pas seulement d'être mon père
quelle trace tu n'aimerais laisser la
pâte à disparition j'aimerais rester
comme un empêcheur de tourner en rond
mais pas uniquement parce que j'aurai 10
ans cuba télé et qu'est ce que tu
aimerais que tes gosses 10 de toi tu es
fini je sais pas ce que j'aimerais
qu'elle dise que j'ai été un bon père
mais j'ai pas le sentiment que je suis
tout le temps tellement je bosse quoi
donc j'aimerais qu'ils me pardonnent et
qu'elles disent d'accord on l'a pas
beaucoup vu mais il a fait des émissions
de télé qui était pas trop mal il a fait
des bouquins qui était pas trop mal il a
fait des gens ne faisaient pas trop mal
voilà quelle excuse mon absence par deux
trois conneries j'aurais laissé
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu